wir testen heute ob die viralen Big Mac
Tacos wirklich gut sind ich glaube jeder
hat das schon mal gesehen deshalb
schnell Durchlauf Hack auf Tortillas
geben und andrücken salzen und pfeffern
und ab in die Pfanne schon ziemlich
Smart man sieht richtig wie der Tortilla
jetzt mit Feuchtigkeit versorgt wird
aber Big Mac Tacos ich weiß noch nicht
so wirklich schauen wir mal drunter ja
sieht ganz gut aus wir geben ein
bisschen tablettenkäse und top und
gehackten Salat jetzt kommt unsere Big
Mac Soße ich bin wirklich durch diesen
Kochprozess bin ich jetzt schon so ein
bisschen offener geworden knappen wir
uns einen der Tacos und wir klappen das
Ganze zu es sieht schon gut aus aber wir
sollten einen Mexikaner holen um es zu
probieren hallo Leo du bist Mexikaner
was sagst du dazu boah sieht köstlich
aus
warte so Italiener sind sauer wenn man
Pizza Hawaii ist bist du sauer wenn du
diesen Takko ist nein lecker ja ich muss
auch probieren ja ja wirklich geil ich
habe besser
erholt immer weg